everybody pants now pants pants buns
pants pants she's had enough call it off
that's not how it works she's out wait
i'm subbing in april no that stuff will
melt the shell off a garden snail
whatever i'm puerto rican i can handle
it
oh my god
okay this ends now
[Applause]
yeah mom you're going back to the farm
and you
hmm you're going back to hell fine i got
what i came for anyway i found your
underground safe i stole half your gold
that's decoy gold
you think i'd leave my gold in a locked
safe buried underground where anyone
could find it
you don't know me at all yes i do i knew
you the minute you were born i intend to
be there the minute you die
ron your family's weird
ready to go yes
your keys please
you gotta be kidding me i'm fine well
we'll let the chart be the judge of that
what are you 5-11 210 pounds three
whiskeys looks like you're just over the
line into impaired you carry that with
you all the time
it comes in handy
and on the back it teaches you how to
play blackjack swansons have a
preternaturally high tolerance for
alcohol my old man used to put wild
turkey on his corn flakes i'm not gonna
argue with you ron we're just gonna sit
and wait until you know you're safe to
drive which would be in about
one hour
insurance is a side bet when you wager
half of your original bet because you
believe the dealer has a 10 in the hole
get off my car woman 20 minutes
the dealer really has an advantage
that's what i get the most from this
hey ron
morning leslie
do you have a good night i did i watched
a really good document what is that this
is what i did last night after i got
home i drank six more glasses of whiskey
and then i finished crafting this small
harp using a bandsaw a spoke shave and
an oscillating spindle sander
[Music]
beautiful but wait there's more here are
some photographs of me drinking the
whiskey you'll notice i'm holding up
yesterday's newspaper so you can tell
that i'm not lying
i feel like i'm in a spa
[Music]
and the winner is
ron swanson for chair
this award is the only one i'd ever give
a damn about
i made my first chair when i was five
but the quality of the wood was wanting
so when i turned nine i used my factory
wages to purchase some beautiful local
walnut
uh thank you
for this
uh this all good
night good
uh
there it is
[Applause]
now that's what i call shooting is this
a hunting game yeah it's fine you want
to play indeed i do
if you'd like i could offer you some
pointers
hunting donna
is about
silence balance and patience
get ready
[Music]
well the game is absurd this gun is
lightweight there's no sight and we are
far too close to these deer would they
not smell us
i want my money back how do i get my
quarters oh my god you are such a sore
loser i'm not a sore loser it's just
that i prefer to win and when i don't i
get furious employee okay let's begin
the barbecue oh hey little guy hey what
are you doing oh no
everyone meet your meat oh no
why are you doing this to us well in my
opinion not enough people have looked
their dinner in the eyes and considered
the circle of life
this is your dinner his name is tom
burn
seriously no i understand that it's
hilarious but that is his given
christian name tom is very smart and
incredibly loyal he's basically a dog a
dog we're going to cook chew and swallow
dude there's kids around here good point
which one of you youngsters wants to
help me drain the blood from this animal
if you do a good job i'll give you the
bladder you can blow it up for a fun
play ball hey ron you're not gonna
slaughter that pig here are you not to
worry i have a permit
this just says i can do what i want i am
the director of the parks department and
this is a park it's not a parks thing
it's against like three laws and a dozen
health codes
fine
barbecue is postponed until i can go
pick up some meat from the food and
stuff let's go tom
no
pig tom
[Music]
we have a wonderfully small number of
clues one is this ticket did you see
this movie about vampires and such new
moon yeah i saw it with april she was so
hopped up on painkillers from getting
her wisdom teeth out i convinced you to
see it with me the teeth
they're yours you were super out of it
you kept yelling team voldemort at the
screen and we were kicked out i was
furious
you only get to see the second twilight
film for the seventh time once do you
remember anything about a key or april
doing anything unusual that day she did
make us stop by the shoeshine stand
before we left because she wanted to
drop something off for andy she had a
real bad crush on him oh
babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married still to the
shoeshine stand
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something
i mean yes my daughter might think she
is old enough to be sexually active with
her boyfriend but i'm sorry 16. that
that just seems too young to be in birth
control you know i was 24 when gail took
my virginity would say we just stand
here
in silence
and think of ideas
for projects
you know what i should do i should lead
a teen abstinence workshop
that might be incredibly effective
evening gentlemen
oh hey rob hale zorp it is a beautiful
night for the end of the world
congratulations to all of you for
reaching the finish line the zorpies are
ridiculous but
like the founding fathers i believe in
absolute freedom of religion
also their ceremonies require the
playing of flutes
i happen to make flutes in my wood shop
flutes are 80 apiece
and recorders are 150. hey they're
beautiful
would you take a check you can cash it
tomorrow sure
[Music]
that was symphony for the righteous
destruction of humanity in e minor by
the late lou prosodovic reminder
these flutes are available for purchase
you can't take it with you people put
your hands together for the one the only
my man mr duke silver
a mighty fine holiday evening to you all
it might be cold outside
but it's about to get warm all up in my
jazz
i of course i'm duke silver
and i would like to dedicate this first
song
to my duchess
[Music]
you're so lucky
i'm going to kill you
[Music]
you